more than a dozen suspected mobsters
have been arrested in sicily
after a businessman secretly recorded an
alleged mafia extortioner trying to
force him
to pay protection money known locally as
pizza
[Music]
the businessman who filmed the video
refused to pay up
confronting the alleged extortionist
with the photos of two prominent
sicilian judges
murdered by the mafia purina is now
among 13
alleged racket victims who've spoken out
in 2018 i had already been threatened by
the mafia
as they had come to ask for racket money
not in the same neighborhood where i
work now
but in another one called capo one of
the mafia's debt collectors had been
around more than once
threatening the workers and myself as
well back then
i filmed everything with a hidden camera
the mafia asking me for money
i turned it over to the police and so
the investigation began
this time around it gave me some
satisfaction to do it
for those who are victims of the mafia
and have never been able to fight back
for lack of courage because they were
simply afraid
there are estimated to be at least 94
mafia clans in sicily kosa nostra and
other mafia organizations mostly operate
in italy's south historically the
poorest part of the country
their main areas of activity include
extortion drug trafficking and illegal
gambling
giuseppe pirino told us again how he
copes with the fear of reprisal
am i afraid of course there is fear
obviously what i did this second time
i'm exposed my family at risk and that's
no trivial matter
i always thank the palermo police they
are fantastic
i feel protected by them because even if
i don't see them
i know they are there i feel protected
but i have to say it's not the police
escort that makes the difference
protection must come from the citizens
protection comes if we all become the
majority
if we are not the minority even the
police cannot provide protection
and unfortunately that's what history
teaches us given all the victims
of the mafia